it's time for drew's news summertime
edition
[Music]
super cool cruise in the good news
convertible
and with me at the desk is a man who
loves that wind in his hair it's rossi
ross matthew
[Applause]
you are wearing the perfect accoutrement
didn't even know
a total accident i love it and we are
joined by seven-year-old journalist and
human ray of sunshine
emmy eat it
[Applause]
look how cute oh emily i'm so excited to
see you
i got my paparazzi thing on ready to be
on drew barrymore again
oh my gosh emmy and i've got my inner
and outer
emmy on because i respect and admire
your news journalism and integrity like
nobody's business
i'm so happy to be reporting the news
with you again
ross and i couldn't wait to see you you
excited about summer
yes my golden birthday what is the
golden birthday emmy
it's where you dress in gold
so it's like golden birthday because
you're turning that age
that's i i did not know that when i do
turn 24 emmy
i'll be having a golden birthday
you have to wear all gold on your golden
birthday
done what am i gonna do next year
because my birthday is february 22nd
so it's 2 22 and then the year is gonna
be
22. that's your double golden birthday
so you have to wear gold everywhere and
dye your hair gold
done answered as long as we can all
celebrate together
that's what i'm that's my birthday yeah
i want to celebrate with you guys all
right are you ready to get into some
stories
yes yeah yeah i'm so excited okey-dokey
first up our friends at the happy
newspaper report
that endangered animal populations are
making a comeback yes india's wild tiger
population is up by
74 i
the know hopeful happy story i don't
know what is
scientists from the british antarctic
survey
have seen a huge increase in blue
whales hi thank goodness we love
blue whales and the sea turtle
populations have grown a whopping
980 percent laughter protection
under the endangered species act that's
amazing i mean what what are your
favorite animals
ah my favorite animal is my bunny he's
right here
his name is brownie oh my god
emmy i have to ask do you recommend
getting a bunny because my daughter
olive that's all she wants is a bunny
i don't think he wants the apple oh my
gosh
he is really cute by the way that might
be the cutest bunny i've ever
seen he has such a personality we have
two oreo and brownie
oreos outside sleeping do they make a
good pet
they're great and fluffy they're
fluffier than a bear because i've held a
bear before
i really have well bunny bunnies make me
very hoppy
[Laughter]
little stupid joke okay emmy i think you
have our next story
so there was a woman named connie here
in idaho
um she decided to start a cafe so all of
her and her friends
they um they got together and
someone stole the money so
my dad posted this story he did an
interview about
um how they got robbed and they got
three thousand dollars donated
are those the women of the cafe
yes they are we were trying to show
great so we're going to show great
support and
she probably might know me from the drew
barrymore show
i bet she will here's my dad
maybe when everything gets back to
normal if you come to new york maybe
i'll come out to idaho falls and see
what the buzz is about
yes how about this i fly to new york
and then when i'm leaving you guys hop
on the plane with me and then
you can just come to our house maybe we
should just all move in together and
live together happily ever after i mean
and then we can do the thing in person
we won't have to just
like travel or anything or do it on zoom
we can just do it in person and we can
show people that have been wronged
and we can make them right just like
your dad does and we can tell
good news stories like the endangered
animals coming back
oh emmy you are just the best thank you
so much for joining us again today and
we have so much to look forward to
because we have
so many things that we want to do with
you yes
i'm so excited for the things we have in
the future
together with you guys oh keep up the
good work emmy
that's right it is awesome
let's keep the good news flowing so we
make everybody happy
and see the good side of life because
it's there
and it's so beautiful bye
[Music]
thank you emmy and thank you rossie
um for being the best news bud in the
news business
and everyone at home thank you so much
for watching and joining us
always we hope you take good energy with
you and we can't wait to see you again
[Music]
soon
you